johnny walker says matt makes great
points about holding companies
accountable that's why the dw doesn't
use youtube or twitter that's why matt
and shapiro don't have twitter pages you
guys use those tools to get large and a
lot of us have no other options if we
want to do something similar to what dw
does
i don't use a lot of these companies
that express views like this but when
you turn around and see large
conservative companies using them while
telling us not to
what is a woman was great there's
nothing offensive in there except for
the people you interview who are hard to
stomach well i've actually never said
that you shouldn't use twitter or
youtube or facebook or instagram or
whatever
i i have said the opposite pretty
consistently i think that if you can use
those platforms
to amplify a message of truth and
rationality
and
morality
if you can do that
then absolutely you should
um
use the platforms to undermine the
ideological agenda
of the people who run them